[Music]
debbie is with us debbie is in eugene
oregon hi debbie how are you
hi mr ramsay hope you're doing better
than you deserve always
if you don't believe me ask people
how can i help you taking my call
i have a husband who has a gambling
problem and um
just can't overlook it anymore and i
don't know what to do i i don't know
what to do i'm
new to your program i i actually found
you through him
um and uh
haven't started the baby steps yet but i
have been watching as much as i possibly
can
on shows especially pertaining to
gambling um on youtube and uh
i'm sorry
how long y'all been married huh
36 years
okay
well
there are a lot of problems here
and um
i'm not going to give you a lot of good
news but i'm going to give you a lot of
truth okay
okay
i've worked with addicts my entire
career
because 100 percent of addicts have
financial problems
that's truth number one
and the truth number two is you cannot
fix enough hide enough
twist enough
to beat this
the gambling addiction is going to win
you can't beat it
i'm seeing that yeah you can't how do i
budget when he's a gambling addict you
can't how do i have retirement how do i
build wealth you can't
because the addiction feeds and sucks
the blood out of everything in the house
and uh whatever the addiction is in this
case gambling
so um
what i'm telling you is is that you
really only have one option for a
prosperous future
and that is to address the addiction
with him
and demand
that he get some help
and if he doesn't if he doesn't then he
is making the choice to separate himself
from you
okay
because i
you know you're
there's nothing you can do
that is big enough powerful enough to
offset the amount of stupid an addict
can do
and he he's scared he's broken he's
stuck
and you say i love you i'll walk with
you but we're gonna walk out of this
we're not gonna walk along acting like
this sitting here
because 100 of the time 5-10 years from
now you're going to have lost everything
your house
all your retirement
your kids college fund
you're going to get lied to you're going
to be manipulated
it's going to get worse or it's going to
get better
and that depends on you and on the
choices he makes from today forward
and so are you guys by chance plugged
into a good church
um i am uh he's not he
uh refuses us when we have talked about
help he you're right he is broken he is
scared
but he refuses to get help of any kind
and years ago we tried gambling
anonymous and he only learned examples
anonymous works
it works
and treatment with a counselor works
doing nothing
doesn't work
and if i'm if if it's my spouse i'm
gonna say i'm gonna walk with you
but i'm walking out the door if you
don't fix this if we don't go to work on
it
because honey ain't gonna be anything
else there's no middle ground with these
guys